the bunting is still up the Prime
Minister busy with a coronation lunch
but as the Royal respite Fades soon
rashishunite will have to face up to a
crushing defeat at The Ballot Box the
local elections were the first big test
of Rishi sunak's popularity with the
public and it did not go well behind the
scenes here there was some hope that he
might be cutting through that things may
not be as bad as expected obviously as
we know now they were far worse the
Prime Minister has been weakened by the
local elections and there are some in
his own party that now want a change of
strategy frankly we produce politics
with soap opera over the last 18 months
immediately prior to that we were master
of always surveyed so I don't blame the
election for being crossed with us the
way we've handled our Economic Policy
isn't incentivizing investment in
productivity and that's what we need to
be that's the conservative party about
nothing if it's not about economic
competence and I'm afraid we are we have
let ourselves due to lots of
circumstances be fighting on a debate
about public spending we're never going
to win that but from the government The
Pledge for now is for more of the same
we've just had a pandemic which has
disrupted many people's lives and has
had consequences for the economy as has
the war in Ukraine which is going on and
we understand the concerns of the
British people you know what we're
focusing on now is ensuring that we cut
inflation and we're having some success
there you know cut the debt uh grow the
economy and make sure that we protect
the NHS
as for labor there's no doubting it was
a good night
but if these results were replicated in
a general election our analysis suggests
they'd fall short of an outright
majority labor can win a majority in
terms of our policies for the next
general election in terms of the results
that I think we will get the next
general election The Best Is Yet To Come
would you be prepared to go into a
coalition with the lib Demps we're not
even entertaining that Prospect Sophie
because directly not even I'm not I just
don't think that is the scenario that
we're going to be in after the next
general election but once the bunting's
down it's Rishi sunak who needs to work
out if there's any way now of keeping
his party in power local elections are
rarely good for the government they
shouldn't be this bad Ali fulsku Sky
News